arrowverse when they asked you to do
arrowverse what was that like what was
that like going on because how long had
it been since you acted with tom or were
lois lane i mean i guess well no because
you weren't lois lane on supergirl you
were i hadn't seen walling for like
well since we ended when did we end
something like that yeah yeah so nine
years were you was it weird was it just
weird jumping into that character
it was like yeah it was very very
comfortable
and easy and it was like fun i loved it
did you get a good response from it
i think everybody was pretty excited
about it that you know
um i usually don't pay attention to a
lot of trolls so maybe it's a skewed
reaction right but i know that people
were really excited about it
being part of the the arrowverse again
i am i wish it had been a little bit
longer but then in a way it's great that
it was
sure because then you know you get in
get out and
for sure well what about what about like
when you did supergirl
and you played you played her mom right
yeah there's no way you look like her
[ __ ] mom
well i am getting a little long in the
tooth as one would say
so this will launch a whole other
session of podcast
but we can do another time because it's
been so much fun but um
it's funny to go from like kind of like
ingenue
and then they don't know what to do with
you so then you just become a mom
and i am a mom it's fine but like
melissa is 31.
was it was it fun or was it boring or
was it it was okay you know what it felt
like being back on small though but not
with my
buddies right like everybody was nice
melissa was super cool
but it it felt so strange because it was
a bit like small though all the
all the sets were like that and all of
the stunts were like that you know
was it as fun i mean in terms of like
the set
was it it wasn't really my family right
like right i felt like although it was
my family it was a new family
i'll have fun um i just found myself
i took my earphones and stuff because
you know what ends up happening right
like if you're on the show
a long time you get to kind of choose
your little space where you go sit
if you're guesting you sit where they
put the bloody chairs
so sometimes i'd be sitting in there and
then they're like trying to have they're
having their conversation
i'm sure they're not even registering me
at all which is fine but i just felt
like i was like in their space
do you know what i mean so i just like
put my earphones on and read my book
okay
like one retreated back into erica but
you enjoyed it it was just like so what
i'm gathering is this because this makes
perfect sense so as an actor when you
come on a
set and you're a guest star or you're
just recurring or whatever
it is the hardest job in the world you
are like imagine smallville we're
established i know
sort of what i'm doing kind of we're all
it's a machine
and then all of a sudden erica durant's
as lois lane
jumps into the machine she's on set for
the first time
and as a guest or as a guest star at
this point we don't know she walks out
of the elevator and sees a naked
stand-in
this is her first day on [ __ ] set and
it's like
how do you feel comfortable so when eric
was talking about supergirl
it's not that she didn't like it or
whatever but she's also
doesn't belong in their family that
doesn't belong but she's not she's just
kind of there and like
she's not part of this really and so
that is very difficult
yeah was your anxiety through the roof
no no
not at all i don't know why i was just
like whatevs maybe i was still like i
just i was only
maybe i'm getting old i like that you're
like
less anxiety i love when i when i'm
taking things in stride and i'm like
maybe you thought
lois lane big i got to be great i'm
nervous anxiety mom
huh let's just do it whatever
it's just like i have like zero horses
in this game
i just came in i did my purple alliance
and then i thought
you